wir sind in einem wettlauf zwischen
virus und impfung und dieser wettlauf
ist bisher noch nicht entschieden
wir wissen nicht wie viel prozent der
bevölkerung letztlich einen schutz
brauchen damit die infect kette durch
das corona virus abreißt
das mag sein dass zum schluss über 90
prozent gegen sein müssen damit wir den
punkt erreichen dass wir keine angst
mehr haben müssen vor dem virus das es
abreißt und bis ein solcher status auf
der gesamten welt erreicht wird sie
können sich vorstellen dass das nicht
kurzfristig erreichbar ist wir sind sie
müssen das sehen wir sind quasi auf
einer zeitachse es ist ein wechsel auf
es kommt auf jeden tag an dass der
impfstoff grascha produziert wird dass
er verfügbar wird dass die menschen
überzeugt sind dass es sich impfen
müssen dass man beobachtet ob neue viren
entstehen die für die man vielleicht den
impfstoff nachschärfen kann und muss und
das kann man auch die rna impfstoffe
sind hochmoderne sind geniale impfstoffe
und man könnte in sechs wochen einen
solchen impfstoff auch nachschärfen
nachjustieren alles das muss aber
geschehen also eine frage der logistik
alles das aufzutauen
sehen wir uns in einem wechsel auf wir
können nicht nur einfach drauf bauen
jetzt haben wir die impfung es wird
schon gut gehen
es ist ein wahrer weglaufen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren